when our president Trump will meet
China's President Xi Jinping in Florida
tomorrow and there is much to talk about
mr. Trump says he needs China's help
with North Korea otherwise the United
States would have to act unilaterally on
the other hand he also accused China of
stealing American jobs and industry well
lieutenant general Wallace erection
joins me now from Washington he's the
former assistant secretary of defense
for Asian and Pacific security fares on
the Barack Obama he's now senior
director for China and the Pacific and
center for the national interest it's a
public policy think tank Lieutenant
General very good to talk to you now
North Korea how strongly do you think
China will try to dissuade president
Trump from acting on his own to stop
North Korea's nuclear ambitions I don't
know how strongly they will try and
dissuade him from acting on this but
past history would indicate that we have
been pretty singularly failing in
getting any restraint on North Korea
over the years since they started
developing their nuclear program so do
you think president Trump is considering
at the far end of the scale military
action I wouldn't presume to indicate
what precisely he is thinking but I will
cite the statements where officials have
said that everything is on the table so
that means that the Chinese will have to
take him seriously and you believe there
is more pressure to be put on Pyongyang
by those in Beijing there could be
Beijing will deny that they have
consistently stated that they have less
influence over North Korea than we think
they do and so where do you see this
panning out where I see this panning out
is we need to start thinking far more
about our allies and friends than we are
thinking about North Korea if North
Korea continues to prove to be
undeterred belen their quest for nuclear
weapons than we need to act on that and
that means telling China that if they
can't
or if they won't help us to restrain
North Korea then we have no choice but
to reinforce our alliance capabilities
and that would involve South Korea of
course and also Japan and others indeed
in South Korea of course literally in
the firing line is it your sense that
South Korea would support potential
military action I don't know that would
have to be asked for them but before we
consider with any consideration and
military action we have to start asking
the questions where can this go and then
what next and I'm not sure that the
answers to those questions will be at
all satisfying to our allies and friends
who of course are very close to North
Korea while we're separated from it by
most of the Pacific Ocean from North
Korea so many huge issues on the table
between the two presidents and trade
looms large and so many comments from
president Trump or candidate Trump on
the campaign trail about the Chinese
damage to the American economy that's
true I'm not in trade may play into
these discussions but but I'm not sure
how well do you think the South China
Sea will feature as well the Chinese
ambitions they're even building
themselves new islands and runways I
think that should certainly be an item
for discussion China is very careful to
make sure we understand their interest
we need to be equally careful to make
sure China understands our interest and
anything that impacts the viability of
our alliance relationships with Japan
the Republic of Korea the Philippines
Thailand or Australia is definitely one
of the u.s. vital interest the features
in the South China Sea are especially
after China promised that they would not
militarize them are certainly a matter
of concern and that needs to be
addressed and do you have a view on that
how important in terms of getting those
hugely important points across how
important
a personal relationship is between the
two presidents their staffs could hardly
be more different well personal
relationships can be overvalued we in
the United States have pinned our hopes
on the fact that one official or another
had a personal relationship with another
foreign leader a more solid basis other
than a personal relationship perhaps
might be one that includes absolute
candor between our two nations on where
our interests lie where we where we have
matters of common interest where we
should cooperate as deeply as we can and
where we have matters of deep concern
where we need to manage to take care of
our interest very carefully and just
lastly is there anything to read into
President Xi being received in
mar-a-lago in Florida and not the White
House well maybe the weather is better
in more elago I don't know but nobody is
more attuned to the power and the values
inherent in protocol and the things that
are communicated by visual symbols so I
have to think that at some point the
visit tomorrow Lagos suits both of our
presidents to do the visit there rather
than the White House lieutenant-general
great to get your thoughts thank you
very much a deeper sparing the time to
share them with us lieutenant general
Wallace see Gregg's in there